it's how long the vector is it
represents like how much force is being
exerted the larger the magnitude the
larger the force for example so here
we've got two points I've drawn the
vector from the initial point to the
terminal point again we did in a
previous video how to find the component
form you take the terminal minus initial
so 4 minus 1 which is 3 5 minus 1 which
is 4 ok triangular brackets but if we
want to find the magnitude represented
by the length of the vector okay also
denoted by these bars right here this
represents the magnitude of this vector
we'll just call it vector V okay what
you do is you take this X component you
square it you take the Y component you
square it you add them together and you
take the square root and that'll give
you the length of the vector so in this
case we have 3 squared plus 4 squared
take the square root we get 9 plus 16 is
25 the square root of 25 equals 5 and
you can see this is just based on the
Pythagorean theorem if you make this
into a right triangle this distance is
let's see 3 this distance here is 4
there's your right angle there and
you're just doing your Pythagorean
theorem a squared plus B squared equals
C squared but some students like to have
a formula here to work with and so what
you can do is you can just think of
squaring the X component squaring the Y
component of the vector adding together
and taking the square root and that will
give you the magnitude again represented
by these these bars here around the the
vector some times some books will use
two bars like that so that just
represents the magnitude so this has
been a little video about how to find
the component form of a vector and then
this is the magnitude of a vector and
we'll talk about some other aspects of
vectors in the next few videos see in
the next video